[Música]
y seguimos hablando por supuesto del
tema del día en el ámbito noticioso
internacional y europeo la renuncia del
Primer Ministro británico por Johnson
para ello quiero saludar Óscar Guardiola
escritorio y profesor de River College
University of London gracias Óscar por
estar con nosotros en directo América de
Francia 24 entonces seguimos comentando
lo que ha sido esta esperada de renuncia
del Primer Ministro británico Boris
Johnson Y cómo le cayó esto digamos a la
a la sociedad británica empecemos
empecemos por ahí el realmente los
británicos querían una renuncia del
Primer Ministro británico Boris Johnson
y además en esta misma orden de ideas le
pregunto como tambalea El Ejecutivo
ahora y la política británica tras el
anuncio de renuncia de Johnson
el público británico no se sorprende
ante la renuncia de Boris Johnson había
sido escándalo tras escándalo
demostración de incompetencia tras
demostración de incompetencia y aún sus
más leales seguidores ya habían empezado
a dejarle el partido conservador ha
perdido cada nueva elección lo que aquí
se conoce con el nombre de violexion y
eso ya estimaba que el destino del
actual ejecutivo de el gobierno del
gobierno británico no tenía más capital
político en este momento ello implica
una serie de consecuencias muy difíciles
para el gobierno británico recordemos
que el centro del gobierno británico es
el parlamento no El Ejecutivo y parte
del problema de Johnson es que nunca
supo delegar quería estar interviniendo
en cada uno de los comités y es por eso
que todos los ministros empezaron a
renunciar Y esa hemorragia de ministros
ahora ha causado la cancelación de casi
todas las reuniones de los comités
parlamentarios Así que el gobierno
británico va a estar en dificultades
para operar
máxime cuando Johnson ha expresado que
él quería quedarse hasta el otoño algo
que ha caído muy mal entre sus
copartidarios y la opinión pública en
general Óscar también es eso es otro
punto que le quería comentar realmente
el Primer Ministro británico se podría
quedar hasta otoño teniendo en cuenta
todo el descontento que hay dentro de su
partido conservador y hasta casi 60
renuncias en estos últimos dos días
conociendo a Johnson es darle pensar que
él va a ser hasta lo imposible para
quedarse él se imagina a sí mismo como
una suerte de héroe clásico griego que
no da su brazo a torcer y si es
necesario muere dando la batalla O muere
llevándose a su reino consigo muchos de
sus copartidarios tenían como en efecto
se hizo claro una amenaza por parte de
Johnson de llamar a una elección mucho
más mucho más rápida Así que
él va a intentar hacerlo no va a ser
fácil pero yo quiere decir que el
proceso de su reemplazo va a ser
altamente divisorio y va a ser muy
problemático tanto para el país como
para el partido conservador hablamos del
partido conservador pero del otro lado
el opositor el laborista se fortalece
con lo que está pasando ahorita dentro
de las filas conservadoras
Hay que ser Francos la ventaja que
tienen en este momento el partido
laborista sobre el conservador en las
encuestas es como dijo el propio Boris
Johnson durante su discurso de renuncia
muy escasa y además el actual líder del
partido
laboristarmer es tampoco popular sino
menos popular que el propio Boris
Johnson lo que parece increíble y sin
embargo ese es el caso ahora bien para
la oposición Esta es por supuesto una
oportunidad lo mejor que podría ser el
partido laborista es buscar algún tipo
de coalición con el Partido Nacional
escocés lo que le daría mayores
oportunidades para luchar una elección
que por supuesto los conservadores van a
intentar postergar como lo dijeron
ustedes antes hasta el final de la
legislatura es decir un año y medio o
dos años más van sin embargo
usar todo tipo de presión y acumular
esta presión en quien sea el nuevo líder
conservador para que el momento
electoral les favorezca también Hablemos
del brexit evidentemente por la que
Johnson por el que Johnson llegó al
poder y por el que va a ser recordado
como uno de sus principales logros al
frente de el gobierno británico pero aún
queda pendiente todavía el protocolo de
Irlanda del Norte Qué tan difícil va a
ser este
palo una rueda Por así decirlo para el
próximo Primer Ministro británico poder
tratar de resolver todo este problema y
toda esta lo que ha sido no el protocolo
Irlanda del Norte que no se ponen de
acuerdo todavía con la Unión Europea
bueno la renuncia de Boris Johnson hace
aún más difícil el proceso de
negociación respecto de Irlanda del
Norte que ya era sumamente complicado el
mismo dijo en su discurso de renuncia
que querría quedarse en el cargo hasta
el otoño con el fin de intentar resolver
ese problema es poco probable que pueda
hacerlo es poco probable que pueda
resolverse y en realidad a lo que
estamos asistiendo es al comienzo de una
crisis constitucional que ya se había
anunciado en el Reino Unido es decir la
posible desunión del reino Irlanda del
Norte es un caso tiene que ver con la
posibilidad de Unión con la República de
Irlanda y la popularidad que está
adquiriendo el partido de mayor
oposición en Irlanda que es shinpain
pero lo propio también está sucediendo
en Escocia y es por eso que ahora es
darle pensar en una co entre el
laborismo el Partido Nacional de escocés
y quizás hasta a Shin Chain así Esta
última no se haga pública por
razones que tienen que ver con la
historia reciente de Gran Bretaña y que
sin embargo son absolutamente necesarias
si es que puede pensarse en un tipo de
modelo diferente para el Reino Unido que
parece ser la única salida a una crisis
constitucional es decir podríamos estar
empezando a hacer testigos de la
conversión del Reino Unido en una suerte
de federación ese va a ser por supuesto
el tema más candente para quienes sea
que reemplace a Johnson Oscar y antes de
despedirlo quería preguntarle por qué
tardó tanto el Primer Ministro británico
Boris Johnson para poder renunciar a
contraproducente digamos en cuanto a su
figura a cómo sale del poder estiró la
cuerda hasta que ya no pudo más
escándalo tras escándalo ahí se mantenía
hasta que no aguanto más a lo mejor eh
qué le decían sus asesores que si se
tenía que mantener O si le decían en
efecto que renunciara y él no quería
pero qué tan sale afectada la imagen de
Johnson eh tras tanto escándalo y
aguantar hasta el último punto
la imagen de Johnson sale muy afectada
pero hay que recordar como que antes que
Johnson es alguien que tiene un concepto
muy alto de sí mismo altísimo por no
decir narcisista es alguien que se
piensa como una suerte de
gobernante
grecorromano es alguien que se piensa de
esa forma heroica se imagina siendo ese
tipo de personaje Y eso que puede ser
una virtud cuando uno está en campaña
ese tipo de mentalidad defensiva
termina siendo una un gran vicio cuando
se trata de gobernar y es precisamente
esta la tragedia a su de Boris Johnson
alguien que tiene un tan alto concepto
de sí mismo que lo proyecta y lo vende
muy bien cuando está en campaña pero a
la hora de gobernar no tiene la
competencia para hacerlo no escucha a
nadie no delega Y esto es algo que ha
demostrado hasta el final él renuncia no
porque quiera hacerlo lo dijo en su
discurso de de su discurso esta mañana
sino porque fue forzado a hacerlo y como
han apuntado varios comentaristas
políticos aquí en el Reino Unido en su
discurso de renuncia no menciona una
sola vez sus múltiples fallos y la
ligereza o la que asumió el gobierno de
este país por supuesto son las gentes de
este país las que están sufriendo los
resultados de esa ligereza Aquí hay una
crisis social política y económica muy
aguda Y eso es algo que el propio
Johnson no ha reconocido en su discurso
de renuncia ni una sola Disculpa ni un
solo reconocimiento acerca de sus
propias limitaciones Eso lo dice todo
acerca del carácter del Primer Ministro
británico